alright let's look at some of the props
that we were talking about earlier as it
relates to these quarterbacks and let's
start with the over/under on the number
of rookie quarterbacks who will be
starting week one the number is two and
a half are you over are you under and if
you're over I want to know the names of
the quarterbacks more than two and a
half it'll be starting I'm under I think
it's going to be just Kyler Murray and
Dwayne Haskins I don't see how Daniel I
mean we know Daniel Jones isn't gonna
start right Eli Manning is the
quarterback forever he is the
quarterback for the rest of time for the
New York Giants and then the other guys
that you're gonna throw out there drew
Locke I mean John Elway said the other
day that did you know Joe Flacco is just
hitting his prime so we know that Joe
Flacco is the guy you're paying him a
lot of money he's gonna start and then
what you know will Grier in Carolina
that's Cam Newton's team still what
other guys that might be the Bengals
I think Andy Dalton still gonna start
day one so I think under and just give
me Dwayne Haskins and Kyler Murray for
your week one starting working
quarterbacks is this the first time
you've ever taken the under ever F I
mean it was it I'm not gonna I don't
know who makes these lines and I'm not
gonna quit I don't like to criticize the
own show but the over-under should have
been one and a half all right who starts
more games this year Joe Flacco or Eli
Manning can we do a push here because
they're both gonna start in 16 they're
both gonna 16 Mike hey there's a new
casino and it may not last for very long
if this is how they're set in their
numbers but a new casino that's going to
be taking bets in Vegas as of June 1 has
Daniel Jones over under it's seven and a
half starts this year I mean it's it's
that's so high it makes me think do they
know something that I don't like are
they getting ready to trade Eli Manning
to someone how in the world is it seven
and a half for Daniel Jones that that
makes no sense I mean that yeah it's
either they know something we don't know
or someone from that casino is about to
Jeff Gillooly
Eli managed absolutely making an
appearance on the show along with Sean
Salsbury I don't know there's a
connection there or not but both names
unexpectedly later do you have on this
Friday morning all right here's one
I I'm gonna take issue with the setting
of this over/under the over-under for
calamari touchdown passes 27 and a half
the rookie record is 27
the over-under for Kyler Murray is 27
and a half what you got
okay so let's reset it because I agree
with you it's not a great line 21 and a
half I'll go over 21 and a half I was
gonna say 23 and a half okay
I think he's gonna end up with 19 20 I
think that Cardinals roster still has
depleted you know talent wise and I
don't know if he's they just aren't that
good you know and and the offensive line
is bad and they don't have a lot of
weapons
David Johnson obviously hopefully has a
bounce-back year but man that team does
not have a lot of talent and I don't
think you can scheme up bad talent in
the NFL so I'll say like 19 20
touchdowns for Kyler Murray yeah here's
the thing about the Cardinals so go back
and look at their transactions this
offseason they've had just it's like
been this weird collection of
recognizable names that most of them are
on the wrong side of their prime but
they're quietly building something I
don't know what it's gonna be but
they're it's just like they're there
they're doing something in Arizona and
nobody's paying attention to them
because it's Rams Seahawks 49ers that's
all we talked about and that's one of
the reasons why you've taken Kyler
Murray so people talk about you again
but I'm just kind of intrigued by what
may happen with these Cardinals all
right one more before we take a break
who leads the rookies in sacks this year
Nick Bocek Quinn and Williams Cleveland
Farrell Josh Allen or someone else I'm
going with Josh Allen and I'm going with
Josh Allen because of the talent around
him the Jaguars defense is still loaded
with guys and if you know the guys
you're playing next to can demand double
coverage or you know can can take away
attention I think Josh Allen will be in
the best spot to succeed right away and
I love what the Jaguars did I love when
teams add to a strength and they say
look our defenses are the strength of
our football team but the minute you
stop you know you stop paying attention
to it you don't keep building it it will
fall off so let's add to that strength
and make it even better I'm gonna go
with Bosa because I think there's a
chance
forty-niners gonna be pretty good this
year if they can keep some of their key
players healthy which they haven't been
able to do but if they can and they can
build some leads that's when the
opportunity for those sacks will arise
and they got plenty of first-round picks
invested on that defensive line so if
they can be pretty good this year and
they can build some leads then that's
when nick bose is gonna have his heyday
you're gonna say that he's gonna play
all 16 games this is I mean we're on the
game of thrones weekend there always
needs to be a stark in Winterfell and
the BOCES always get injured that's the
same famous sayings we rolled out yeah
well hold out or hold out
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports